哈囉大家好
歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
今天又來到了10分鐘心理學
關於今天要講的10分鐘心理學呢
其實跟我們之前有一集
40歲前你應該知道的事情有關哦
那一集呢很感謝大家的支持
所以就是收到了很多的回應
那很多人留言
有些人說很感謝老師的提醒
覺得自己好像很有幫助
那也有些人就說
哎呀我覺得這個東西
如果大家都覺得是不是這麼有道理的話
那是不是雞湯啦
沒有關係我們偶爾喝喝雞湯
不過我寫的比較像是我自己個人的經驗
那是我自己個人經驗的集結啊
所以它比較不是什麼很嚴重的大道理
可是執行上其實並不容易哦
不過我也有看到開始有一些朋友留言
那我看到這些朋友留言
看起來有些也覺得
哦大家其實很不容易
就是有些人看到這一集之後
反而變得更焦慮了
覺得說哎呦你講的東西
我根本都沒開始做
那我人生是不是就完蛋了
我是不是就永遠來不及了
我現在都幾歲了
然後我現在都沒有做到這些
看著留言的很多朋友
他們好像都已經開始做了
甚至有人說他20幾歲就開始做了
所以我就覺得好焦慮哦
然後我就覺得越看心情越差
今天的這幾十分鐘心理學
我想要分享給這些有這種感受的朋友聽哦
那就是為什麼越想變好
卻會越覺得自己沒有用
這一個部分是我們日常生活很常遇到的
那也是我們在講內耗常常會遇到的根源
可是為什麼我們常常會在
我好想要變好
明明我也想要找尋一些資料
找尋一些可能性
找尋一些方向
想要讓自己變好
可是當我聽到可以怎麼改善
或是怎麼做會比較好
卻發現自己沒有的時候
我就會遇到很大的挫折感
甚至會讓我覺得
耍耍去啦（台語）
我就爛啦
就躺平啦
好不好
必須誠實跟大家講一下
躺平這件事情不是問題
甚至我覺得是我們自己在找方式
讓自己能夠在現在的這個狀況去生存
可是我們現在要討論的
其實跟另外一件事情非常有關
那就是那一種在面對自己做不到的時候
的自我打擊
還有自我效能感
非常重要的關鍵
所以為什麼我們有時候會覺得
我好像越努力
越想努力
卻越覺得挫敗呢
例如說我看到像這樣子的影片中
我看到下面的留言
我看到我自己跟這個影片對照起來的一個狀態
我反而會覺得很挫折
實際上焦慮啊
壓力啊
它其實是怎麼產生的呢
我常常會講說
你會常常去注意別人的一些標準
你就會覺得焦慮
因為你沒有把注意力放在自己身上
這樣子說
我個人覺得是一個非常重要的方向
但如果我們要再講細一點
焦慮、壓力出現最大的原因
其實是理想的自我跟現實自我的差距
就會形成焦慮跟壓力
假設今天我在考試的時候
說各位請在三秒內寫出一個數字的1
欸 你壓力會不會很大
你會不會焦慮
不會吧 誰不會寫啊
我們就說我們沒有什麼氣質性的問題的話
手可以動的話
要寫1沒那麼難嘛
就這樣畫一個
而且還有三秒的時間
因此我們可能會感覺到
如果有時間限制
也許有一點點壓力
但是這並不會讓我們很焦慮
因為任務並不困難
可是如果我跟大家講說
請在三秒之內寫一個烏龜的龜
你要是寫不出來的話
就代表你這輩子就會沒用...
當一點用都沒有的時候
你壓力就會很大吧
然後可能就會開始對我生氣
為什麼寫不出來烏龜的龜
就會一輩子撿工
你說清楚啊
所以我們會發現一件事
任務太過困難
以及我對自己的標準太高
以及我對自己理想太高的時候
我們又感覺到現實的自己
沒有做到這件事情的時候
它就會形成很大的焦慮跟壓力
因此當我在看
欸有人說就是做這些事情
好像會對他很有幫助
所以他一直在做這件事情
可是這些事情也許是在我的
人生的思考上
我從來沒有想過的事情
我覺得這些東西對我來說
非常的生疏
我的日常生活可能花了
非常非常多的力氣
都在想著怎麼生存
可是也許我自己也有一套
我認為我到這個年紀
應該要知道跟我做得到的事情
但是當我的注意力沒有在這些事情上
而是在那些別人的標準
別人他覺得這樣好像很好
可是我卻做不到的映照之下
我就會感覺我的自我效能是低的
我就會覺得我自己是不好的
於是我就會感覺非常的糟糕
很焦慮
那什麼叫自我效能感
之前我有一集哦
十分鐘心理學 跟大家分享「自信」
自信是自我信任的能力
我相信我自信的這個定義
跟其他人不太一樣
但是我認為自信就是自我信任的能力
那自我效能感又是什麼
它跟自信有一點點像
但是呢如果我們把它講得更白話一點
就是我覺得我做得到
所以自信是自我信任
而自我效能就是我覺得我做得到
我覺得我可以做
我覺得這件事情我可以
所以當我們寫1的時候
自我效能感很高
當我寫烏龜的時候
自我效能感可能就沒那麼高
差不多是這個感覺
但是呢我們日常生活中
跟自己講話的方式
其實會影響到我們的自我效能感
這也就是為什麼我在40歲前
你應該知道的事情
有提醒大家我們要怎麼樣
建立跟自己的關係
自我效能感簡單的說
其實跟自己的關係很有關
一個是當我自我效能感比較低的時候
我願不願意給自己鼓勵
讓自己可以充電
然後呢再去訓練我的一些能力
以及呢在我有時候面對一些事情
遇到困難
我感覺到我自己好像沒有辦法做得那麼好
我沒有真的覺得我做得到的時候
我可不可以在那時候鼓勵我自己
跟我自己說
嘿其實我知道這件事情有點困難
那沒有關係
我們把這件事情慢慢拆解成
你能做得到的方式
讓我們一一做到
這就是讓我們增加自我效能感的方式
也是讓我們慢慢的感覺到這件事不會很焦慮
而且我可以走在我想要的道路上的
一個非常重要的關鍵
但如果我們對自己要求很高
我看著別人的一些狀況
我看著別人的一些前進的一些速度
我就覺得我沒有像他這樣
我就很不好
我很不應該
這種就是所謂的社會比較理論啦
那就是我會從別人的表現
去參照我自己現在的狀況
有些人很習慣做這件事情
這很正常
為什麼呢
特別是在我們現在臺灣的社會
如果你從小你的父母就是讓你
是在比較中長大
比如說你的手足們就是大家會互相競爭
然後呢你爸媽呢
就算你是就是唯一唯二的孩子
爸媽都還會講說
你知道那個巷口王太太的兒子啊
那個隔壁三叔公的小孩啊
還有那個誰誰誰的怎麼樣啊
人家都怎樣怎樣
你看看你怎樣怎樣
然後你就很想跟他講說
我跟你講郭臺銘他賺那麼多
人家的爸爸是郭臺銘
我爸爸還不是隻有賺這樣
齁 這個不能講
可能會吵架這樣
好
可是我的意思就是
當你很習慣是被這樣子比較中長大的
你的生存策略之一就會是
在你遇到一些不確定的狀況
你不曉得你的目標在哪裡
你也有一些焦慮的時候
你的第一個反應就是先看別人
你會先看別人把別人的標準拉進來
然後看看他現在在這裡
我現在在哪裡
如果我發現我現在的位置
在比他前進一點
啊我就安心了
但如果現在我發現他的位置跟我位置
我沒有像他那麼前進
我就會覺得非常的焦慮
這也是我們有時候在面對這種自我效能感
會遇到這種會覺得很挫折的狀況
就是好像人家都很容易
然後都非常遊刃有餘
可是呢
我卻沒有辦法把這些事情做好
這會帶給我們很大的打擊
因此這樣的打擊呢
就又勾起了另外一個很重要的情緒
那就是羞愧感
羞愧感這件事情
我覺得在我們文化裡面
也是一件非常麻煩的事情
真的我真的覺得
一切都要怪我們的文化訓練
怎麼說呢
我們的文化訓練其實是非常不鼓勵
失敗、挫折跟做錯事
我不知道各位有沒有經驗
在你做錯事的時候
我們的文化裡面
其實並不是鼓勵你去負責任
然後鼓勵你去負完責任之後
知道怎麼處理
然後承擔起來這件事情
把它當成既得的教訓之後
能夠調整
這件事情就結束
沒有我們的文化很重要的是
這是你的錯
你有沒有出來負責
負責的方式是什麼
那就是辭職、離開
然後不然就是被大家罵
然後被大家就是羞辱
然後說天啊
你怎麼會做出這種事情
真的是太丟臉了
怎麼會這樣子
我們的文化非常習慣用這樣的方式
去處理失敗、挫折
所以呢
我們常常會遇到一個狀況
就是我做錯事的時候
我被人家說我需要改進什麼時候
我看到別人有
但我做不夠的時候
我第一個反應 就是覺得自己很丟臉
我覺得很羞愧
我覺得我沒有做好
而沒有辦法就事情本身去看說
欸那這件事情對我的幫助是什麼
我又想做嗎
我又可以怎麼調整
我們就注意力就很難放在這種
讓我們自己有成長的一個觀點去看
而是會覺得
天啊
我好害怕被人家發現
我是不夠的
所以我一定要假裝我自己夠
這是羞愧感的一個非常重要的來源
而我認為這個羞愧感的來源
有很多時候是來自於文化的訓練
所以我在關係黑洞這本書裡面
有講到一句話
然後很多人就說
他受到這句話很大的鼓舞
就是你要記得你做不好的時候
只是你做不好
而不是你不好
你沒有做好這件事情是可以調整的
你訓練之後就會做好
它是可以改變的
可是這跟你個人的自我價值
完全一點關係都沒有
那時候PO這一句話的時候
也是會有一些
欸我覺得蠻有趣的
男性居多
有一些那種年紀比較大的男性
會來指教我說
做不好
什麼叫做你做不好
不是你不好
你都覺得要把責任丟到別人身上
你就不會改變啊
你就一定要怎麼樣
所以我就覺得
喔我們父權社會的這種
嚴厲的這個狀態
我反而不會覺得他是在罵我欸
我覺得是
他從小是被這個訓練的
也就是說我們今天做錯事
就一定要被罵得跟豬頭一樣
就一定要承擔出那個很大的羞辱
我們才會改變
我們不相信
我們會為了我自己想要變好
去做改變
我只相信只要我做錯了
我一定要被羞辱到一個極限之後
我才會願意改變
我覺得這個文化
其實是很令人傷心的
所以我覺得如果你發現
你在看到別人有而我不夠的時候
我會引發這麼大的羞愧感
請留意一下
是不是因為你從小有被做這樣的訓練
沒有關係
就算是有
現在的你
可以為你自己做不一樣的訓練
那我們可以做什麼呢
我們要怎麼樣可以從
我想要變得更進步
可是一旦我覺得我不夠
我就會很無力
我又會什麼都不想做
然後我就想躺平
於是我永遠想進步
但永遠沒辦法進步
我到底可以做些什麼好
好先講進步這件事情
進不進步這件事情當然看你
還是回到一個很重要的立場
就是我想要變成怎麼樣的人
我想要精進我怎麼樣的技能
我想要讓我的情緒變得穩定
等等
這些東西都是自己的選擇
你自己能夠安於你的狀態
這是最好的狀況
就像我在做諮商這件事情
沒有每個議題都要處理
你能生活你就生活
你遇到困難才去處理
你想處理的事情
不過回到這個無力感
那我們怎麼樣去擺脫這個無力感
讓我自己可以比較
能夠把自己的力量
放在自己想前進的方向呢
第一件事情哦
我會非常鼓勵大家
如果我是因為看到這個目標太大
所以自我效能感變得很低
記得烏龜的龜
那我們就是拆解目標
拆解目標的意思是什麼
比如說假設我影片裡面有講說
大家要有健康的生活
那我們的目標變成
那我就是我的內臟脂肪要降到多少
我的體脂肪要降到多少
我的體重要降到多少
然後我肌肉量要多到多少
我覺得這樣才是很健康
然後我的數字要怎麼樣才可以
讓我覺得我有健康的路徑邁進
可能這個東西它的標準都很高
如果你這樣子看你就覺得
我要達到這個標準
我一個禮拜要重訓三次
我每天要跑步五天
然後每次跑步要超過四十分鐘
我才有可能可以降到我的內臟脂肪
那我吃東西要怎麼樣
你有沒有發現它變成是一個
非常非常困難的任務
因此在這麼困難的任務執行上
就會變得很不容易
我覺得這是一個很有趣的一個事情
就是請你先把它拆解成一個簡單的步驟
例如說
我只要每天早上起來都有喝一杯水
我吃飯前願意喝一杯水
讓自己吃東西慢一點
或者是我一個禮拜裡面願意有幾天
就是我平常都是坐電梯進公司
我願意有幾天的早上
我是走樓梯爬樓梯進公司
那麼我今天的運動量就做了
把它拆解成你可以做得到
不會壓力很大的一個目標
是讓我們增加自我效能感非常重要的關鍵
因為我們大腦就會覺得
喔我今天做到了我好棒棒
這個感覺會讓你更願意往下挑戰
就是所謂的跨出你的舒適圈
這件事情我非常非常有感
因為我有跟大家分享
我當初剛開始跑步的時候
我真的是一個完全不跑步的人
我當初剛開始跑步的時候就是先走
我可以去操場走一圈的這個方向開始
喔我可以走一圈
我可以走三圈
我可以走五圈
那我可以慢慢的變成我可以跑半圈
走半圈
然後再慢慢變成我可以跑一圈
走一圈
然後再慢慢加上去
到現在我可以大概跑八到十圈
就是看我當天的狀況
基本來說這件事情它不是一蹴可幾的
但是呢這時候就會遇到另外一個狀況啦
我們就可能會遇到說
可是老師就是這個目標齁
雖然這樣可是有時候我們真的很難做到
我會建議你在你做這件事情
因為你會有一個舒適的狀況
就是你習慣做這個小目標嘛
小目標做好之後你會很舒適
但是呢要跨越到下一個目標
稍微讓它難一點點的時候
你會開始
哇好辛苦喔好累喔很不容易喔
這個時候我會建議大家
我不知道大家會不會常常在這個時候就會開始說
你爭氣一點
你要努力啊
你要怎麼樣啊
或是說
你怎麼今天沒有怎麼樣
你怎麼可以一直這個樣子
會不會有這些焦慮
用這樣的方式講話
我想問問大家
你用這樣子跟自己講話
成功經驗到底有多少齁
我自己個人就是一個草莓族
我誠實的說我這從小就覺得我就是個草莓族
我是一個不能就是太辛苦的人
所以在這個時候當我覺得
例如說我今天跑到第五圈
即使我現在說我跑到八到十圈
但其實有的時候我要跑到第五圈
我還是覺得很痛苦
我還是很覺得
想說跑到第五圈是最舒適的狀況
啊那個
跑步完趕快回家了啦
大概也有這種感覺
那我要怎麼讓自己可以往下跑完那三圈呢
通常在這個時候我就跟自己說
慕姿你超棒的！
你現在已經跑完五圈了
你看我們現在已經在第五圈了
你有沒有覺得你現在好像還有一點體力
那不然這樣好不好
我們不要決定要跑八圈
我們先跑完這五圈
等一下你再跑多跑半圈看看
看你行不行再跑下去
然後我就這樣子
就是像有點像哄自己一樣
在喊跑半圈
欸不錯欸
這個半圈跑下去你好像還有力氣欸
我們把這一圈乾脆跑完吧
然後跑完六圈
欸你看六圈了耶
再一圈就七圈了耶
七圈就差不多跟我們平常的
那個八圈差不多
你要不要再試試看再跑半圈看看
我們就是用這樣的方式
然後慢慢哄慢慢哄
有時候我就是這樣哄著哄著
我就跑完十圈了
所以我覺得那個自我的鼓勵
跟自我的激勵這件事情
其實是我們在遇到一些困難的狀況
非常非常重要的關鍵
改變跟自己說話的方式
改變跟自己相處的方式
我覺得這是今年度非常非常重要的事情
然後另外啊提醒大家
改變說話的方式還有一些方法
比如說
在你會覺得你看我就是沒有做到
我不行
我永遠都沒辦法做到一些事
當把「我永遠」沒有辦法
把這個詞改成「我還沒」
我還沒做到這件事
我還沒就是能夠做到我的目標
但我現在在努力了
請把你跟自己講話的句子不一樣
大家心裡想一下
你把你不行
你沒辦法改成你還沒
那個感覺不一樣
還沒就是我有可能做得到
每件事情都是有可能的
時間長短跟你花的力氣在不在而已
當然你說那我現在要建一個火箭
我做不做得到
欸我覺得不見得真的完全做不到
所以我個人覺得這是一個蠻有趣的地方
那就是有些人會覺得
他常常在做一些事情的時候
他其實能力非常好
可是他很難跨出舒適圈
或是他很難去往自己的目標前進
我覺得常常會跟這個思考有關
因為他們都會先想比較困難的部份
我覺得先想比較困難部份的人呢
其實做事情都是非常仔細
而且能力非常好的
因為要在這個壓力底下
承受得住
還可以把事情做好
如果你是這樣的人
你是非常非常厲害的
你要花一半時間去做事情
一半時間跟自己打架
你還可以把事情做好
你看你有多強
所以我現在想鼓勵你
把那一半跟自己打架的時間省下來
所以你一定要區分
我現在做不到這件事情
我現在做的還沒有到我的目標這件事情
跟我不好這件事情
跟我沒有價值這件事情
是分開的
也就是請你區分你的自我表現跟自我價值
我的表現不等於我的價值
請務必記得這件事情
特別是如果你從小是
表現跟價值整個綁得很緊的人
去區分這些事情
對你是非常非常重要
回過頭來喔
我剛好今天錄這集
十分鐘心理學的時候呢
就前幾天去上了
唐綺陽老師跟索愛客的節目
然後呢這一集有就是邀請到簡少年
所以老師們呢
就都在分享關於
2026年我們到底該做什麼
那唐老師有講到啊
2026年有一個非常重要關鍵
就是我們要就是把注意力放到自己身上
知道自己想要什麼
因為這一年會非常非常多的改變
而且外面可能是非常非常混亂的
混亂不見得是不好的混亂
就是有很多就是你會不停覺得
怎麼又有這個怎麼又有那個
就是有很多變化
那簡少年就說
今年他最建議的就是躺平
就是大家都躺平
就是不要太用力
那為什麼不要太用力呢
其實意思是說
大家要把注意力回到自己身上
你不要用力用力在
其實不一定對你有效的方向上
所以怎麼去辨識什麼對你有效
會很重要
所以回到這兩位老師的提醒
我覺得反而就讓我感覺
2026年是一個
跟自我關係
好好培養的非常重要的一年
所以像我們現在在講啊
你可以怎麼跟自己講話
你在遇到挫折跟困難的時候
你願意這麼跟自己說話
你會成為你自己最大的支持
你會成為你在困難的時候
能夠陪你自己跨越那個困難
最大最大的關鍵
而跟自我關係的培養
是我認為今年可以度過非常多難關
的一個非常重要的關鍵哦
所以提醒一下大家
我在TED剛好就是去年底有一個演講
然後呢裡面就是講到關於內耗的部分
這個部分呢
我那時候就講了一句
在這個演講結束中有講了一句話
我想要送給今天的大家
那就是
能跟自己過得去
你就沒有事情過不去
因為很多時候我們過不去的
不是事情
是我們內心對自我的一些失望
還有一些情緒感受
好的那麼今天十分鐘心理學
希望對大家能夠有幫助
如果你喜歡我們今天的分享
歡迎按贊訂閱開啟小鈴鐺
Podcast的朋友也歡迎給我們五星好評
留言告訴我你對就是這一集的一些想法跟心得
每一個大家的分享我都會看哦
謝謝大家
那麼周慕姿放心說
我們下次見囉
拜拜